[MUSIC]
First of all welcome, it's really
great to have all you here.
It's it feels so good to be
doing reunions again in person and
getting to several people
on campus.
And it's really wonderful to
have y'all back here to see each
other and celebrate your reunions.
I think what I'd like to do with
this session is actually most
of the time just hearing your
questions, and having a discussion.
But I'll spend a few minutes at
the beginning just kind of giving
yo a little bit of an update on
the school and
telling you how things are going.
I thought I'd just start by saying,
so yesterday we had the first
faculty senate meeting of the year
at Stanford and my colleague the
dean of the medical school spoke.
And he said something that just
really resonated with me,
he was talking about the pretty
challenging last 32 months that
we've had at Stanford, including
four entire quarters that were
pretty much on Zoom when we had no
undergraduates on the campus.
The MBA students in the MSX
students were here on campus but
classes were largely on Zoom.
And the faculty were teaching from
home on their computers.
And he said that his dominant
feeling looking back over the last
32 months was gratitude.
There was gratitude for
the incredible effort and
adaptability and
resilience that faculty showed in
having to rethink teaching after
doing it the same way for years and
sometimes decades.
That the students showed in having
goodwill to get through
the pandemic, that our staff showed
and having to navigate things.
And the goodwill that alumni showed
and helping to support the school
through a pretty tough, and
the university through
a pretty tough time.
And so, that really resonated with
me and even more than gratitude for
the period going through COVID,
I have felt tremendous gratitude
being back on campus.
I came to Stanford for
the first time as an undergraduate,
I was 17 years old.
And I've been here spent most of my
life since then here on campus,
22 years on the faculty,
six years here at the GSB as dean.
And basically have loved every
minute of being on this campus for
all that time, but have never felt
more appreciation for the campus
than I have this year and last year
when we brought people back.
And there's lots of reasons for
that actually, but
part of it is the GSB in particular
university as a whole, but
the GSB is a unique place.
There is really nowhere else
like it,
I think anywhere else in the world.
It is a place where on the one hand
we have these unbelievable,
brilliant, scholars and
faculty who are milling around it.
Some of you I know this morning
came and saw Hido Ben's,
our faculty member speak.
Hido won the Nobel Prize in
economics last year.
His colleague Bob Wilson won it
the year before.
This week Carolyn Bertozzi our
colleague in chemistry,
won the Nobel Prize.
That's how you get to be on
the faculty with at Stanford and
learn from in classrooms.
It's amazing.
And we have a more than our fair
share of those people here,
even relative to the chemistry
department in the engineering
school.
And then you pair that with
the incredible leadership potential
and action orientation and
ambition of the students who come
into the school every year.
And that mix of great ideas and
great leadership potential ambition
drive to action.
There's just about nowhere on
the planet that puts those things
together in one place.
But of course what makes it not
just kind of a bunch of independent
people doing interesting things,
is all being together, and bumping
into each other in the interacting.
And whether it's students
connecting or people in classrooms,
or just you all being here running
into students to faculty,
the mixing it up
that happens on the campus.
That's where the alchemy is,
the magic of Stanford and
missing that for 18 months.
Just really brought back how
special that is, and
how fortunate we are to get to be
here in that environment, and
how much potential there is.
The potential energy of having
those interactions is
just incredible.
It's really great to have you back,
and this is the first real reunion
back and kind of full on post COVID
that we've had.
And so it feels so
good to see all of you here and
get to interact and give
you a chance to be together, and
I hope you get a sense of just how
vibrant the campus feels right now.
It feels incredible to walk in
everyday.
Let me say one more thing and then
I'll just open up a discussion,
which is if I had to
pick one other.
I Lloyd started yesterday, and
Lloyd Manor from the school said
his one word, his feeling right now
was gratitude, and
I said that resonated.
If I had to pick one word,
it would be opportunity.
That we have been through just in
the last few years such a period of
extraordinary change in the world,
and change in business,
change in society politics.
And a time when there's first of
all been incredible changes in
technology.
I mean, we're going to go through
a rethinking of work this year for
the first time in 100 years
probably of how people interact and
work.
Sheet societal changes,
more awareness about issues like
inequality, the role of business
and fostering opportunity,
climate change.
This year at Stanford,
we have a new school for
the first time in 75 years of
school of sustainability and
we're doing all kinds of stuff this
year with sustainability school
around business sustainability.
I know some of you came to
the session earlier today.
And when you have a period of just
incredible change in disruption in
the world, and when people are sort
of thinking in particular about
the role of business and addressing
those changes, addressing some of
the challenges we have.
That's a great time to
be at the business school.
But that's just a great time to be
on campus,
because you've got people
are thinking they want to debate,
they want to talk about it, they
want to come up with solutions.
And that is such a great feeling of
opportunity right now.
And you're going to get to hear in
a few minutes from Adman one of our
faculty who has been really at
the forefront of this, and
she set up a initiative at school,
the Corporations Society
Initiative, about five years.
She really anticipated actually
a lot of the changes that
are happening, thinking about
the purpose of corporations and
the role of business.
So she'll talk about some of
the things that she's been doing.
And that's been a big area of
activity for us at the school.
So, as we think about
the curriculum and faculty research
and our engagement at
the university and with the world.
So let's stop there, and
I'll open up and
I'm happy to hear any questions you
have about just about anything.
So I think I'll just leave it to
you to sort of drive the direction
we go and then Okay.
>> So, John, thank you.
Thank you John for amazing work
that's been done at the school.
And I wanted to ask you especially
with the opening of the new school
sustainability this past week,
what the vision is for the GSP and
interaction with the new school and
addressing urgent issues in
the climate crisis?
And specifically,
if you could comment on the student
protest about the call for
university divestment from fossil
fuels.
>> Yeah, okay, thanks, Gordon.
That's a great question and broad.
So, let me actually take the first
part and
then I can talk about the specific
issue on investment.
So actually, before I check our
relation with the school statement,
let me just actually step back and
say, this year one of our major
initiatives that we're going to
launch this year and probably my
top priority for this year is to
launch an initiative we've been
calling the business government and
society initiative.
And it's organized around a set
of pillars,
topics, where we think the business
will could have a big impact on
issues that are at the intersection
of business and society.
One of those is sustainability,
business sustainability.
One is around the effects of
technology, governing, and
guiding technological change in
ways that will be broadly
beneficial for humanity.
One of them is around the future of
markets and institutions.
You'll hear more about that from
when she talks about governance
issues, purpose of the corporation,
institutions that
underlie business.
The sustainability piece of that,
Stanford made a decision two
years ago that we were going to
make a major investment campus wide
in climate and sustainability.
And that was decision made by our
president Marc Tessier Levine and
the provost.
And there was a committee that
looked at different ways we could
do that.
And they actually came back with
two models, and interesting
university governance story.
They came up with two models for
how could the industry make
a huge push in sustainably,
be the leading university?
One model was what they were
calling a college.
So that is every school would make
kind of a push, and then you would
network them across the campus and
the other was to create a school.
And we decided to create a school,
I was a school advocate.
And the reason I thought the school
would be great is the school is
an ecosystem.
School has faculty,
you have to pick who what research
you're going to do, what you're
going to teach, and so forth.
And so, two years ago,
we made that decision,
president made the decision we're
going to have a school,
preschool at Stanford at 75 years.
And now, it's launched with
incredible philanthropy
from John Doerr in a big way.
As soon as that decision was made,
there was a question of how will
the other schools be involved?
You need to have business involved
if you're going to think about
climate change, energy transition,
innovation that's going to scale
solutions, technical solutions that
might come out of great
engineering and science.
And so we got started at the
business school having discussions
initially among the faculty, but
then including lots more people.
And we came up with a plan for
an initiative that Bill Burnett,
one of our faculty members has been
leading.
And now it's a joint
initiative with the Doerr school.
And so when the Doerr school opened
in September, we had six faculty
who took joint appointments over in
the Doerr school.
We have 70 MBA students who
are doing a joint degree with
the Doerr school.
We have a whole set of classes that
are getting introduced this year,
we're running 17,
this is actually crazy.
I don't know why we're doing this
scale, but we're running
17 conferences in business and
sustainability, one every two weeks
all through the year.
So climate finance, accounting,
net zero operations, it's a little
overwhelming actually.
I think Anada is running one on PG
and in the wild fires that I've
gotta figure what I'm going to say
at, but I will figure it out on
that, don't worry.
And then we're going to announce in
a couple of weeks a new
sustainability entrepreneurship
program that we've
put together with the Doerr school.
I'm really excited in the kind of
vision that we've had about
the partnership.
Is that this is an opportunity as
we have with other Stanford
schools to marry that incredible
disciplinary expertise in energy,
and innovation, and technology, in
the rest of campus with leadership
entrepreneurship management of
the business school, and
that's just a dynamic combination.
That's the combination that
students need to be successful and
to solve problems.
You asked about the divestment from
the sort of issues around,
it was question about weather.
So there's been a lot of debate at
Stanford about forming the school,
about whether Stanford should take
money from fossil fuel companies.
I would say opinions are divided at
the University.
There's a very vocal group
of students and some alumni and
faculty who feel very strongly that
we shouldn't take money from
energy companies.
And then there's other people who
have a different view that
the university should engage
broadly, and we have the principle
of academic freedom which says
faculty pretty much have the right
to work on whatever they want, and
that discussion is going to play
out this year, basically.
The dean of the new school has
issued a statement last year with
some principles and is doing
a listening tour and they'll have
to sort that out at the new school
over the course of the year how
they how they want to do that,
yeah, >> There was [INAUDIBLE] in
the Wall Street Journal in the last
week or so
about decline in applications,
major business schools, Stanford
was not mentioned in the article.
What's the experience here,
and does that suggest a change in
the profile for
people who are applying?
>> Yeah, so the thing that I
understand about business school
application was I think all of you
know some of us were very,
very tight to the labor market.
When the labor market is high,
business school
applications are down.
And when the labor market business
school applications are up or
counter cyclical,
for obvious reasons.
In last year,
the labor market was smoking high,
and our applications were down.
And I think they were down by
16% or so.
In this year the labor markets,
I guess it's really hard to tell
depending on the numbers you look
at, how you look at them,
there might be very tight or
it might be cooling off.
So I guess we're going to find out
in the next couple of weeks what's
going on.
In terms of our class composition,
the truth is, it hasn't really
mattered our applications.
I think we're down off our peak,
which was maybe five years ago or
something.
We had our peak year four years ago
and then we were down a little bit,
COVID was very weird
with applications,
we were down a little bit.
Other schools were hugely volatile.
We have two things going for us,
one is we take a very small number
of students.
Almost everybody we admit these
days comes, about 90% of
the students we admit come, and
that's yield is really high.
And so,
we're very fortunate in that sense,
and we've got a class of 2000 that
was fantastic and
then we have a class of 420.
So we're in a pretty good position
Other schools are much more
vulnerable to fluctuations in
the market than we are.
But I'll just say one more
thing about that,
where it shows up for us.
So there has been a lot of
discussion about whether there's a
sort of secular decline in sort of
two year residential MBA programs.
And there has been actually,
if you look at numbers.
Now part of that is that statistic
is about overall MBA programs.
And it would be a little bit like
if you asked Stanford's Dean of
admissions for undergraduate and
said college enrollment is
declining in the US.
Are you worried that Stanford won't
have any students in
the undergraduate class?
And he'd be like, well, no,
we had 60,000.
I don't know how many he had, but
it's sort of conflating things that
are a little bit different and
that's a little bit true
for us too.
But it is a reflection of something
that is affecting us,
which is career paths have changed.
And so in fields like finance, in
consulting, in tech companies, you
can go far in your career without
ever stopping to get an MBA.
So an MBA for many years for
some people perceived it was
a necessary rung on the ladder.
And I don't think anyone thinks of
it that way.
Now the good thing is we never
thought about it that way, and
I hope none of you ever thought
about it that way.
We've always thought of the MBA at
Stanford is not how do you get up
one rung on the ladder?
It's about how do you see every
possible path you could take and
get the skills to do any of those
things.
So that change in overall MBA,
the sort of secular changes in MBA
programs in some ways have played
to our advantage.
Because no student comes in
thinking I need to get this degree
to get to my next job.
They can get to
the next step just fine.
They come in thinking how is this
going to set me up for a whole
career of different opportunities.
And in some ways that's good,
that plays to what we were
doing anyway in our program.
But we still keep a close eye on
the year to year admissions
numbers, yeah?
>> Thank you for the opportunity.
You refer to quite a few changes
in motion globally.
Can you maybe kind of unpack
a little bit what are the top
changes among them that really make
you think about what's
the strategy, or how do you deliver
the ambition of the school?
>> Yeah, so I'll mention a few.
I mean, I think, one,
we already talked about climate and
sustainability and
that's a big priority for us.
And certainly with this incredible
opportunity with the university
having a new school to really be at
the forefront of thinking about
the response to climate change and
energy transition.
And I think that's a great
opportunity for
us whether it's entrepreneurship or
thinking about finance operations,
different aspects of management.
The school in Stamford is deeply
wedded to Silicon Valley.
And so changes in technology
particularly in digital
technologies, they come from here.
We are the source of so
much of that innovation and change.
And to my mind, one of the big
things that has happened here,
one is just,
there's been such a revolution in
areas like machine learning, and
artificial intelligence, and data,
and algorithms.
And that's a great opportunity for
our students because the
combination of the technological
change and the business model
changes that intersection is such
a powerful place to be.
And it's a place where our students
have the opportunity to get to.
When I came to Stanford as
a faculty member 20 years ago and I
worked on the economics technology,
it felt in Silicon Valley
like we were really divorced from
the world.
We're just creating
these great things.
There's a lot of bad stuff going
on, but not here.
Here's where we just create these
amazing products that make
everyone's lives better.
Everyone here has a more
sophisticated complex view of
the world now, or
at least I think we do.
Or at least we need to have one.
So that's a really important
area for us.
And it's an important area for
the whole university to be thinking
about the potential from
technology, but
also the complexities of how do you
guide the direction of technology?
What are the second order effects,
and so forth.
So just to pick two,
those would be, and
Nat's going to talk about a sort of
another broader set of governance.
But I'll let her do the talking on
that one.
But if I had to pick two or three,
those would be them.
Okay, in the front.
>> [INAUDIBLE] >> Yeah.
>> Couple of years in the way
teaching was done,
in the way students interacted,
in all the aspects of how that
happened, and now you've come back.
What do you see as
the key takeaways from that in
terms of going forward?
What did we learn?
Just as you said,
we're changing the way we work and
rethinking the last 100 years.
Is that happening in
the education process and how?
>> Yeah,
okay, that is such a great,
great question.
So during COVID, I read that there
was a university group,
the long range recovery group.
And I led that group with a faculty
member from the H&S, and
that was the question that
was asked of this group, and we had
people from across the university.
And we basically came back and
said, we had two answers
to this question.
One of the answers was, this is
a time of incredible innovation.
It really did force everybody to
think about how to teach,
how to use classroom time,
how to use technology.
I mean, it's a revelation what you
can do with technology.
Who knew that on Friday night,
the provost could send an email at
Stanford and say,
on Monday morning,
we will be teaching online.
And then on Monday morning,
we were teaching online.
The whole school was online.
We did it over a weekend.
Of course we were terrible at it
when we started, I mean truly bad.
The first day of COVID after we
went online, I was giving a guest
lecture in one of the classes.
It's a class taught by
Peter Wendell and Eric Schmidt.
And I was their guest, and
we get into the class and
I welcome the class.
And I say, welcome to
the GSB online on Zoom and
they're waving at me and I'm like,
why are they waving at me?
And they say the camera is that
way.
>> [LAUGH] >> So
we got better over 18 months.
[LAUGH] And
some of that's coming back I think
into the MBA classroom,
people are using more Zoom to bring
speakers in more.
They did lots of video,
people made videos, they used that,
more flipped classrooms,
types of stuff.
The place where we're really
using it actually is in our
shorter flexible programs,
executive programs.
We had to stop all
our executive programs basically.
We have a big executive education
business. It generates about $80
million a year in revenue.
90% of it was on campus summer
programs.
It went to zero during COVID for
two summers.
And instead we basically spent 18
months just trying out new things.
And some of them were not
successful and
some of them were amazing.
So I'll just give you
a couple examples.
So one is We started this type of
program in education where these
are just two or three-day short
intensive refreshers on
a particular subject that faculty
are keen to talk about.
Turns out it's very hard to fill
for two days to talk about Fintech
or talk about AI or talk about
bitcoiners or something, wherever
the faculty are interested in.
Getting a global audience
to spend two days on Zoom kind of
just diving into a topic of
excitement to faculty, no problem.
So this year we're actually we're
going to work with the engineering
school and we're going to set up
a platform for
faculty across Stanford to offer
the Stanford intensives.
We could have done that before
COVID but we probably would never
have come up with something,
like we wouldn't have bothered or
just wouldn't have come to mind.
And so now some things like that.
So that's been one great source of
innovation.
Okay, that was the first lesson
kind of a revelation.
The second revelation was what I
started with,
which is MBA education is just much
better in person.
I mean, it is just like people
were talking for COVID.
Maybe the MBA will be a hybrid
degree people want to Zoom in,
turns out, no, our students do
not want to Zoom in.
They spent the whole COVID in
the residences chafing against
the COVID restrictions.
And when they came off,
you just see that that is like,
it's all about interacting,
it's all about the people you meet.
And the faculty and
engaging in the classroom and
mixing it up, and
it's an affirmation of the value of
what happens here on the campus.
And part of the lesson of COVID is
we just gotta get back to
doing that.
Get people back together.
My gosh, okay,
how about in the back,
you had your hand up for a while.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Here, the flip side
of that are the risks.
What are there two or
three risks that are biggest
in your mind about all this?
>> Yeah, I mean there's,
gosh there's always risks.
When I think about sort of
the things that worry me,
a lot of things that worry me
are just about sort of people.
The people on the campus you're
responsible for people and so
during COVID that was
certainly something that I
worried a lot about.
And even now, I worry about issues
like student mental health and
issues like our students.
And our faculty and folks that they
came through a hard time and
it's still pretty challenging.
Institutionally I think in some
sense it's Stanford, the biggest
risks at Stanford are that we
become, this is going to.
I don't want to say something
that's going to sound bad for
our peer schools.
But the best thing about Stanford,
the thing that brought me here,
particularly it brought me here as
a faculty member.
And kept me here on the faculty for
20 years instead of going somewhere
else is that Stanford is a
relentlessly forward-looking place.
Stanford is very unusual in higher
education.
If you think about it,
higher education is,
how many industries are there?
We're the top three organizations
in 1705,
are still in the top five today.
Higher education is like that.
And what's amazing about Stanford
is just 7 years ago,
Stanford was a regional university.
And it just has had this incredible
ascent over many, many years.
Partly because of the people like
you who went through the school and
have gone on an added luster to
the reputation of the institution.
And because the faculty and
the current students and all that.
And what has driven that is
that it's a very forward-looking
entrepreneurial, innovative,
not afraid of change place.
And so the biggest risk to us is
that somehow we would rest on our
laurels or we would be complacent.
Or we would start spending too much
time sort of tried to protect the
things we have instead of keeping
the drive and the forward-looking
and that opportunity mindset that
has made this place so special.
>> Remember the recruiting rush of
the summer with the shrimp cocktail
and the buffets, and especially
the second-year recruiting rush.
>> Yeah. >> You talked about how
people are rethinking work.
>> Yeah. >> How has recruiting
changed from what it was then
>> That is such a great question.
How is recruiting change?
That is such a great question.
So here's the interesting thing
about the GSB.
This is in recruiting.
This is true even before COVID.
Basically, all of our peer schools,
two-thirds of the students get
their jobs through on-campus
recruiting, and
through their summer internship.
We were in a situation before COVID
where 10% of our students were
taking their summer internship and
turning that into a job.
And only about a third of our
students or less were getting their
jobs through on-campus recruiting.
Instead, we had moved already
before COVID, basically to a world
of kind of network job search.
Where our students were instead of
kind of waiting for the recruiters
to come to them, we're basically
looking around through alumni who
was a huge resource.
Thank you for
returning people's calls.
I'm going to come back to that in
a second actually, because you're
so important actually in this.
Or they were looking at LinkedIn or
certain times and
then going out and
proactively trying to find places.
And some of them still go through
recruiting for consulting firms or
private equity or what have you.
But a lot of them were already in
this kind of new world of
decentralized network search.
We had to go through a huge
transition in the way we support
careers in our career management
center over the last couple of
years to support that.
And COVID, I think just sort of
a little bit excited that, I mean,
recruiting now has moved to Zoom
in large part.
At least the first rounds of
interviews and so forth, but our
students were kind of ahead of the
curve in this as they often are.
The last thing I'll just say about
this with about the role you play,
you play a big role in our job
placements.
And I'd say two things about it,
one is just to come back to the
theme of gratitude I started with.
During COVID when we started the
pandemic, we had a catastrophe with
the student job searches because
the internships got cancelled and
the job market dried up.
And when we were in March of 2020,
our Career Centre came to me and
to the rest of the folks in
the school leadership.
And said we don't have enough jobs
just posted at the Career Center to
get our students jobs.
We were about 150 jobs short, and
internships short.
And a time I wrote out to all of
you and to the other alumni,
they said we need help.
And actually,
that was one of the most amazing
responses that I've ever seen from
an alumni population.
The GSB alumni credit 300 jobs and
internships in about three weeks.
And all of our students got great
opportunities.
That was incredible.
I mean, seriously incredible.
And one of my colleagues who
teaches here has taught here for
a long time and
is an alum of another school on
the East Coast that sometimes
people think of as a pure school.
>> [LAUGH] >> I hope I'm not being
recorded.
No, [LAUGH] I am being recorded.
But I'll tell the story anyway
because it's a good story.
So he said, he was and he said,
at my alma mater the alumni book is
really thick, it's hugely thick.
He said, any industry you look
in there's tons of people.
But no one calls you back.
The GSB books its kind of thin and
thinner, pretty thick but not as
thick but everyone calls you back.
And that's amazing and
that's such a huge asset for
our students.
I just told our students today
because they were asking about
what's going to happen to the labor
market this year.
That's a real ace in the hole
for them.
So you all are the ones who make
that happen.
So thank you for everything you do.
And thank you for everything you
do more generally for the school.
We're so lucky to have
this alumni population.
And it's so great to
get to see you here today and
I hope you have a great weekend.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]